of course in some ways you you push that
to the extreme once you get into the
area of performance capture and and
becoming creatures that do not even
exist can you tell us how you got into
performance capture in the first place
well I got a call from from Asha I was
actually playing Bill Sikes at the time
we were shooting in Prague and and I got
a call from my then agent saying look
there making this film of Lord of the
Rings down in New Zealand and they want
someone to do the voice for a digital
character in in Lord of the Rings and
and and I said well look of the Rings
has got you know a dozen really good
parts in it can you get me up something
decent and I don't really I'm not a
voice actor and I don't know what I
would do a voice for a digital character
so can you just see what so so that so
then they said well it's we're not quite
sure what it is exactly but they but but
it's it's Gollum and it's and I was
going oh right I remember Gollum from
The Hobbit I read The Hobbit hadn't read
Lord of the Rings at the time and they
said with it we're not quite sure works
but you've got to audition for it so I
thought well how am I gonna get Edition
for I'm not a voice I really am NOT just
I'm not some one of those actors who's a
like a miracle can go in and or do
voices or impressions or you know that's
not me I have to go into the character
to find a voice as part of building a
character and so I started to think
about how I could approach this and I
was at home reading I started reading
Lord the Rings and he was gonna be
auditioning I think you know how am I
gonna hell am I gonna do this so anyway
so I started reading and you know Gollum
Gollum is you know obviously the power
of the Ring gulfs this this being and
and twists and and and contorts him and
he's called Golan because of the way he
sounds and he says he says Gollum Gollum
you know and I'm thinking how am I going
to how I can approach this you know
where where does this character carry
his guilt and pain where does and and it
was his throat I saw
let's think okay so manias throat's
really constricted okay well maybe maybe
the what what is the ring well the rings
of a bit like an obsession it's maybe
he's like a maybe it's like an addiction
it's and he's maybe he's like an addict
you know so I started to think about
along the terms of him being like like a
heroin addict or or cocaine like someone
who is obsessed by something and unless
they get it they're gonna go crazy so
and then I was thinking I'll have
physically how am I gonna find this and
I wanted to find something that the
effect of the ring had an involuntary
action on made him spasm in some way and
and then this is gospel truth my cat
came into the room and did his name as
days no longer with us and came in and
started coughing up fur balls and he was
coughing up fur balls the whole of his
head through to the tip of his tail was
doing this kind of this kind of weird
action and he started like that so that
then became sort of sort of yeah you
know and that was that was sort of the
genesis of at that voice so I went in
for the audition and I jumped up over
the football player thinking and jumped
up on the chair and sort of started
doing a version of which wasn't me
actually it was a version of of that for
that for that of casting director John
Hubbard who sat there and he was reading
off lines and he just went oh no he
thinks this is terrible I think this is
a complete disaster all I've really
screwed this one up and anyway so that
then word got sent off to Peter Jackson
and it came back though wanted to
actually meet me so I met with them at
the American Church in London and as
soon as I laid eyes on Peter Jackson and
his wife Fran Walsh I sort of fell in
love with them I literally fell in love
with him when I first met him and he
said no look we are we don't he
explained the process I would he said I
want an actor to play Gollum but we
can't finally manifest him on screen
with an actor because you could never
cast someone who's three and a half foot
tall and that wiry and skinny and
emaciated and
and with a slightly larger head we'd
never find an actor to do that so we're
using we're gonna animate him finally or
he'll be manifested using CG finally but
we want an actor to play him because we
don't want the actors playing Sam and
Frodo to have to imagine what what's
going on inside this guy's head you know
by looking at a tennis ball on a stick
so because at that time that's how
visual effects were created and and so
so so so I said well look I'd love to
died you of this challenge and he said
yeah we're we're towing this idea of
using this technology which is coming
out of the medical industry called
motion capture it went from sort of
thinking I was just gonna be doing this
voice to actually being down in New
Zealand for a year-and-a-half onset work
you know you know I turned up I did some
lots of lots more sort of physical
research worked out how Gollum would
move and and think and feel and be and
behave and my first shot in Lord of the
Rings was you know obviously was three
films but they will shot concurrently
and my first shot was scene 729 which
was half way up Mount Doom you know
trying to stop Frodo and Sam getting to
the top and so I so I found myself in
New Zealand six and a half thousand feet
up a mountain in a lycra suit with the
crew not knowing where the hell I was
there and beat attacks and laughing at
me and and so and we did this scene and
then and then when he saw what I was
doing he said okay okay we're gonna sort
of reconfigure this we're not gonna just
animate the character and we're gonna
have a we're gonna literally copy every
single movement that Andy does and we're
gonna copy every single facial
expression that he's doing and he's
gonna become the template for this
digital character so this this began
this you know that this went on and on
you know throughout the course of Lord
of the Rings it got refined and changed
and technology was evolving as we were
shooting and when we came to the end of
the The Return of the King Peter Jackson
invited me over to lunch it had to be my
birthday and he gave me he gave me one
of the original Rings from Lord of the
Rings and said this is for you
and would you like to play King Kong I
was thinking what he said yeah well
that's the next thing we're doing and
we'd like to play King Kong and I was
like so this this was the moment really
that was this the second epiphany of my
life other than you're gonna become an
actor which was I've just been playing
this three and a half foot ring junkie
and now I'm gonna play a 25 foot gorilla
this surely is the end of typecasting as
we know it this is brilliant
this is amazing this is a tool which
enables the actor to become anything you
want to be it's like mr. Ben you go into
the you know you go into the shop and
you dress up and you can become anything
you know
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]